wire cuts faster these days I I look at
like let's say dinner with Andre versus
a you know the bourne identity or even
beyond that and things have definitely
sped up yeah and and and scenes are
shorter and there and them it's cut much
faster what do you think that is I think
I'd be part of it I think a little bit
as in patients from the part of the
islands but I think a lot of it is
because the Odyssey is is more people
watch so much now so much more than ever
I think of everything that there is a
level of just the quality of the viewers
are higher they understand and they
perceive and they they notice things
faster that's just like an understanding
and and reacting to two the intimate
material there's much faster now than it
used to be and this was actually a
little bit of a challenge with Cara
because we knew because it was a love
story and because the way Todd was
directing the actors and because the way
the actors were doing delivering the
lines in camera then we needed to slow
down we needed to like okay this is not
we needed to we had to earn the audience
trust that the pace that we were going
for was the right pace I couldn't be
like she talks she talks he talks
sorry you had to be like she talks she
reacts she reacts she talked like a
little bit like a half a step slower
than you expect some of the scenes to be
it was just something that we are trying
to to make sure that that that pace was
was the right pace and then people we
kind of like guiding you through that
that kind of rhythm if that makes sense
you